is there anything else now that you're
here and you're talking that you want to
clear up that was misinformation
I like liking like like like like like
like like like like like like like like
uh you know like like like like like
like like
and like like like like I was like okay
like like like like slacking like like
like like like like like like like like
like like like like like to like like
like like like like like she's like it's
like like like like
I was like Hey like like like like I'm
like like looking like like the guy like
it's like like like it's like like just
like you know it's like like we're like
hissing and it's like like it's like
like that like like like like like like
like I can be annoying but just like
like like like like I was like like
physical like like really like like like
like he was like like like like like
like it's like like like like Katie like
had like Christina like like and then
like like and like like you know what I
mean like like I mean like like like
like like like like dude and I'm like
like he's like like like like like like
like like like kind of like like like
like like and like like she's just like
like like it's like honey like like like
like like like like like I'm like like
like like like like like like like like
like like like like like
like like like I'm like like like like
like like saying like like to like
and then like like
I'm like like I like like she's like I
was like like like and like like to like
like like like it's like like
you like like like in like like like
like like like she was like I'm like I'm
like like like it just was like like
it's like like like a might be I was
like you know like but like like I'm
like like also like
like like like
bring out like I'm like it's like dude
like like like like and I'm like like
like like like like like like like like
like
you know like it's like like it's like
like ugh I'm like what it's like you're
like oh like like but they like like
like like like just like like
you know what I mean like I'm telling
you like like it's like like like you
know what I mean like like I'm like like
this day like they're like like for like
like you know what I mean like like
they're like like stuff like and like
like I feel like like being like like
like I felt like I felt like it's like
like you know and just like kind of like
like even like that Penny just that
started the music Jackie
I can't hear anything I'm not wearing
headphones no I'm talking to you you
can't hear me no well now yes I can but
not I can't hear the music you don't
wanna the podcast over you